The force is strong in my family.
My father has it.
I have it.
My sister has it.
You have that power too.
Woohoo!
Chewie, we're home.
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So new Star Wars Episode 7 trailer. The cast was at
Celebration so this is gonna be a breakdown of
the new footage they post and some of the things
they said. Really the big takeaway here is that the
original cast is in the trailer.
We don't really see their faces, with the
exception of Han Solo and Chewbacca,
but this is Luke Skywalker putting his
metal hand on R2.
There's been a lot of rumors about
what's going on with Luke Skywalker in the movie but
because his voice sounds fairly normal
in the trailer
I'm not expecting any vast left turns
for the character.
There are so many elements from the
Original Trilogy in here though, it's so much fun,
like Vader's melted helmet, the Millenium
Falcon. We learn a little bit about this desert planet,
it's actually not Tatooine, it's
called Jakku, no idea how that's
spelled right now. I think it's J-A-K-K-U.
But it's the same desert planet that we see in the
last trailer, where the new cast meets.
Remember, John Boyega's playing Finn. He's a
stormtrooper as far as we know.
They were fairly non-committal when they
were asked about that at Celebration. They were like
"Can you confirm that he really is a
stormtrooper and he's not just masquerading as one?"
And they wouldn't say anything so
he could be on some sort of infiltration mission.
He could be like a rebel masquerading
as a stormtrooper.
This is actually what the full stormtrooper
gear looks like. It's fairly close to the
Original Trilogy just with the
slightly modified helmet. This is Rey. I
think that's her hand that's accepting the
lightsaber in the trailer.
There's a lot of theories that she might
be Princess Leia's secret daughter, like
Han and Leia's daughter.
I don't know if that's true or not. Because
he says "The force is in my sister" when
she's accepting the lightsaber I think
there's some sort of family connection between them.
They also made a big deal about all the practical shots they did instead of, you know, versus CG.
There will be a lot of CG in the
movie but if you look in the backgrounds
you can see all these big sets that they built,
they look really beautiful,
really beautiful and dirty like they should. There's something so awesome and steampunky
about the classic Star Wars universe and
obviously they're shooting on film
too, they're not shooting it on digital tape.
J. J. Abrams called this is as much a western,
like a John Ford Western,
as he did a sci-fi picture so I just
think that's really awesome 'cause I'm a big
big fan of John Ford.
Obviously the Empire is still a very big
deal in this movie. Just forget about the
Expanded Universe New Republic stuff.
That does not exist.
Power abhors a vacuum so even though,
you know, a bunch of people died in the battle
of Endor other people inside the
Empire rushed in to fill that leadership vacuum.
So there are still very evil people leading the Empire
right now. And if you've been watching Star
Wars Rebels the Inquisitors are actually gonna be big
thing. They've tried to set that up in
Rebels. Here's a better shot of Poe Dameron
in his X-Wing formation that we had
in the last trailer.
There's a lot of theories that his
character's gonna be involved in the
X-Wing spinoff movie.
Here's a better shot of that crossguard lightsaber
in action. And everyone's still debating on
whether or not that's affective. Here
we can see the shit hitting the fan on Jakku.
Whatever's going on between Rey and Finn.
He's not wearing stormtrooper gear anymore so
he could be a rebel that was just
masquerading as a stormtrooper temporarily.
And we see BB-8 in the background here
rolling around. That's actually practical,
it's not CG. Like they built a robot that rolls
around on set.
I love that her outfit is a nice mirror for
Luke Skywalker's in Episode 4.
Kathleen Kennedy made a big deal about
talking about how, like, new women
new women of power are going to come
into the Star Wars universe
via these movies. Rey is just one example of
that. Here's a really good shot of Kylo Ren. I think
he's going to be the main antagonist, like
the Darth Vader type character of Episode 7.
There're a lot of rumors that this could be
Adam Driver's character but there
isn't any confirmation on that and he
wasn't at Star Wars Celebration.
New stormtroopers with the new Imperial
banner in the background.
These are the new updated TIE Fighters. Obviously
they've updated
all the ships because remember this in
the future so they made slight
modifications, probably improved things a little bit.
Here's another awesome scene on a
practical set. Look how big this is.
None of this is CG with the exception
of the blaster fire. This looks like the
new Star Destroyer design.
I don't think it's a Super Star
Destroyer, it doesn't look quite big enough.
Here's one of the new chrome troopers.
They haven't fully explain what their
role is in the Empire.
We can probably guess that they're just Spec
Ops. BB-8 on the Falcon.
This actually looks like it appears early in
the film, like before that big
explosion when they're running away.
It seems like based on this shot that Han
Solo and Chewbacca
rescue them in the Falcon. Them flying
into the downed Star Destroyer is also a nice.
twist on flying into the Death Star.
Slightly modified TIE Pilot design, all
practical set.
So we finally see Han Solo on screen with
Chewbacca. He's actually, like, the first
original cast member's
face that we've seen on screen, first
original cast member that's not a droid.
When he says "We're home Chewie" he could be
talking about a lot of things. He could
be speaking in a metaphor
or fighting the Empire again or they
could be on a planet.
Han Solo's from Corellia. We don't know if
they're gonna visit that place in the movie.
I don't think that he's talking about
Corellia though. Something really telling I
think is the fact that none of these
original cast members appear together
with the exception of Han and Chewie.
Han and Chewie are off in one part of the Galaxy doing
their own thing. Princess Leia's of on her own.
doing her own thing and then Luke
Skywalker's getting his Ben Kenobi on
hiding out somewhere.
Obviously the new cast, like the new main
cast members, will be coming together in this film.
I'll be interested to see how long it
takes for the original cast members to meet up
or if they even do. Episode 7 is really like a transitional film, like they'll be transitioning the story
to this new cast of characters. So as we
move forward in the trilogy
you'll see the original cast less and less
and the new cast more and more.
But overall, awesome new trailer. Really
awesome seeing Han Solo for the first time.
Harrison Ford wasn't at Star Wars
Celebration because he's still recovering from
his plane crash but it was really fun seeing
Carrie Fisher and Mark Hamill cry on stage.
So I might do some more Star Wars videos this
weekend. Be sure to subscribe to get them.
I've got some Daredevil that I'm working on.
Trying to get through everything before Game of
Thrones again on Sunday.
So lot's of awesome stuff. I'll also be, I'll be
Tweeting about Celebration all through
the weekend so if you wanna follow me on Twitter and Facebook there are links for that in the description.
I know it's been a little while since they posted a trailer so you guys can actually click her
here for the last one to watch that again
and you can click here to catch up on all
my Marvel Avengers videos.
Thank you so much for watching. This is gonna be
so much fun. Everybody, let's high-five,
I'll see you guys tonight.